since its start in Seattle in the early
1970s Starbucks has open shops all over
the world that includes European nations
where coffee culture was already well
established but one place they dared not
tread was the coffee centric land that
helped founder Howard Schultz shape the
chains character in the first place that
is until this week Seth Doane reports
this line wasn't for Milan's Cathedral
or castle but for Italy's first
Starbucks its fortunes come on for
curious still a man well a borassi who's
from Milan joined hundreds of others
curious but defiant this will not become
my cafeteria inside Starbucks
transformed this former post office into
a 25,000 square foot coffee roastery
it's a testing ground for ideas like
using liquid nitrogen to freeze the ice
cream for an affogato and an elaborate
attempt to woo and Wow the country that
invented espresso
you see Starbucks is written here but
this does not resemble any Starbucks
I've ever been in this is really more of
a most a theme-park of coffee
they've dispensed with some of the more
American concoctions note Frappuccino on
the menu but they have imported American
pricing which is high for Italy at
Milan's company no cafe where Schultz
was said to have been inspired
they've been brewing espresso for a
century and customers were unfazed by
the American import will Starbucks
change the way Italians are drinking
coffee no we are Italian coffee
Starbucks has struggled in closed stores
in other countries with a strong coffee
culture including Australia New Zealand
and Israel to succeed in Italy it'll
need more of this you see that the
Brazilian coffee being toasted in this
super huge machine then you drink it
it's the complete experience it's
incredible wow you've been in here for
15 minutes and you're a convert
literally changed my mind
for CBS this morning Saturday Seth Dome
Milan